good afternoon
my colleagues and I remain squarely
focused on our dual mandate to promote
maximum employment and stable prices for
the American people
we understand the hardship that high
inflation is causing and we remain
strongly committed to Bringing inflation
back down to our two percent goal
price stability is the responsibility of
the Federal Reserve without price
stability the economy doesn't work for
anyone
in particular without price stability we
will not achieve a sustained period of
strong labor market conditions that
benefit all
since early last year the fomc has
significantly tightened The Stance of
monetary policy
we have raised our policy interest rate
by five percentage points and we've
continued to reduce our Securities
Holdings at a Brisk pace
we've covered a lot of ground and the
full effects of our tightening have yet
to be felt
in light of how far we've come in
tightening policy the uncertain lags
with which monetary policy affects the
economy
and potential headwinds from credit
tightening
today we decided to leave our policy
interest rate unchanged and to continue
to reduce our Securities Holdings
looking ahead nearly all committee
participants view it as likely that some
further rate increases will be
appropriate this year to bring inflation
down to two percent over time
and I will have more to say about
monetary policy after briefly reviewing
economic developments
the US economy slowed significantly last
year and recent indicators suggest that
economic activity has continued to
expand at a modest pace
although growth in consumer spending has
picked up this year activity in the
housing sector remains weak largely
reflecting higher mortgage rates
higher interest rates and slower output
growth also appear to be weighing on
business fixed investment
committee participants generally expect
to subdued growth to continue in our
summary of economic projections the
median projection has real GDP growth at
1.0 percent this year and 1.1 percent
next year well below the median estimate
of the longer run normal growth rate
the labor market remains very tight over
the past three months payroll job gains
averaged a robust 283
000 jobs per month
the unemployment rate moved up but
remained low in May at 3.7 percent
there are some signs that supply and
demand in the labor market are coming
into better balance
the labor force participation rate has
moved up in recent months particularly
for individuals aged 25 to 54 years
nominal wage growth has shown signs of
easing and job vacancies have declined
so far this year
while the jobs to workers Gap has
declined
labor demand still substantially exceeds
the supply of available workers
fomc participants expect supply and
demand conditions in the labor market to
come into better balance over time
easing upward pressures on inflation
the median unemployment rate projection
in the SCP Rises to 4.1 percent at the
end of this year
and 4.5 percent at the end of next year
inflation remains well above our longer
run two percent goal
over the 12 months ending in April total
pce process Prices rose 4.4 percent
excluding the volatile food and energy
categories core P core pce prices Rose
4.7 percent
in May the 12-month change in the
Consumer Price Index came in at four
percent and the change in the core core
CPI was 5.3 percent
inflation has moderated somewhat since
the middle of last year
nonetheless inflation pressures continue
to run High and the process of getting
inflation back down to two percent has a
long way to go
the median projection in the SCP for
total pce inflation is 3.2 percent this
year
2.5 percent next year and 2.1 percent in
2025.
core pce inflation which excludes
volatile and food and energy prices is
projected to run higher than total
inflation and the median projection has
been revised in the SCP up to 3.9
percent this year
elevated inflation longer term inflation
expectations appear to remain well
anchored as reflected in a broad range
of surveys of households businesses and
forecasters as well as measures from
financial markets
monetary policy actions are Guided by
our mandate to promote maximum
employment and price and stable prices
for the American people
my colleagues and I are acutely aware
that high inflation imposes hardship as
it erodes purchasing power especially
for those least able to meet the higher
costs of Essentials like food housing
and transportation
we are highly attentive to the risks
that high inflation poses to both sides
of our mandate and we are strongly
committed to returning inflation to our
two percent objective
as I noted earlier since early last year
we have raised our policy rate by five
percentage points
we have been seeing the effects of our
policy tightening on demand in the most
interest rate sensitive sectors of the
economy especially housing and
investment
it will take time however for the full
effects of monetary restraint to be
realized especially on inflation
economy is facing headwinds from tighter
credit conditions for households and
businesses which are likely to weigh on
economic activity hiring and inflation
the extent of these effects remains
uncertain
um
in light of how far we've come in
tightening policy the uncertain lags
with which monetary policy affects the
economy and potential headwinds from
credit tightening the committee decided
at today's meeting to maintain the
target range for the federal funds rate
at five to five and a quarter percent
and to continue the process of
significantly reducing our Securities
Holdings
as I noted earlier nearly nearly all
committee participants expect that it
will be appropriate to raise interest
rates somewhat further by the end of the
year
but at this meeting considering how far
and how fast we've moved we judged it
prudent to hold the target range steady
to allow the committee to assess
additional information and its
implications for monetary policy
in determining the extent of additional
policy firming that may be appropriate
to return inflation to two percent over
time
the committee will take into account the
cumulative tightening of monetary policy
the lags with which monetary policy
affects economic activity and inflation
and economic and financial developments
in our SCP participants wrote down their
individual assessments of an appropriate
path for the federal funds rate based on
what each participant judges to be the
most likely scenario going forward
if the economy evolves as projected the
median participant projects at the
appropriate level of the federal funds
rate will be 5.6 percent at the end of
this year
4.6 percent at the end of 2024 and 3.4
percent at the end of 2025.
for the end of this year the median
projection is a half percentage Point
higher than in our March projections
I hasten to add as always that these
projections are not a committee decision
or plan if the economy does not evolve
as projected the path for policy will
adjust as appropriate to Foster our
maximum employment and price stability
goals
we will continue to make our decisions
meeting by meeting based on the totality
of incoming data and their implications
for the outlook for economic activity
and inflation as well as the balance of
risks
we remain committed to Bringing
inflation bringing inflation back down
to our two percent goal and to keeping
longer term inflation expectations well
anchored
reducing inflation is likely to require
a period of below Trend growth and some
softening of labor market conditions
restoring price stability is essential
to set the stage for achieving maximum
employment and stable prices over the
longer run
to conclude we understand that our
actions affect communities families and
businesses across the country
everything we do at the FED is in
service to our public mission
we will do everything we can to achieve
our maximum employment and price
stability goals
thank you and I look forward to your
questions
[Music]
thank you Colby Smith with the financial
times I'm curious what gives you and the
committee the confidence that waiting
will not be counterproductive at a time
when the monthly pace of core inflation
is still so elevated interest rate
sensitive sectors like housing while
they felt the drag of the past fed
actions have started to recover in some
regions and financial conditions you
know most recently we're easing
so
I guess I would I guess I would go back
to the beginning of this tightening
cycle to address that so as we started
our rate hikes early last year we said
there were three issues that would need
to be addressed kind of in sequence and
then of the speed of tightening the
level to which rates would need to go
and then in a period of time over which
we'd need to keep policy restrictive so
at the outset going back to 15 months
the key issue was how fast to move rates
up and we moved very quickly by
historical standards then last December
after four consecutive 75 basis point
hikes we moderated to a pace of 50 of a
50 basis point hike and then this year
to three 25 basis point hikes at
sequential meetings so it seemed to us
to make obvious sense to moderate our
rate hikes as we got closer to our
destination
so the decision to consider not hiking
at every meeting and ultimately to hold
rates steady at this meeting I would
just say it's a continuation of of that
process the main issue that we're
focused on now is determining the extent
of additional policy firming that may be
appropriate to return inflation to two
percent over time
so the pace of the increases and the
ultimate level of increases are separate
variables given how far it it we have
come it may make sense for rates to move
higher but at a more moderate pace
I want to stress one more thing and that
is that the committee decision made
today was only about this meeting we
didn't make any decision about going
forward including what would happen at
the next meeting including we did not
decide or really discuss anything about
going to an every other meeting kind of
an approach or really any other approach
we really were focused on what to do at
this meeting
so there was no kind of initial debate
about the possibility of July any sense
of the initial support at this stage for
that move so again we didn't we didn't
make a decision about July I mean of
course it came up in the in the in the
meeting from time to time but really the
focus was on what to do today I would
say about about July two things one
decision hasn't been made to I do expect
that it will be a live meeting
power
uh thanks Howard Schneider with Reuters
I was just wondering if you could help
us understand the narrative here because
it feels like there's been a level shift
in the in the dots
um stronger GDP uh less of a hits on
employment slower progress on inflation
and I'm wondering in this sort of
where's the disinflation coming from the
labor Market's going to be stronger it
looks like it's not coming from there
demand is not coming down all that fast
according to GDP you've doubled your
your estimate of GDP so what's the
what's the narrative here it seems like
it's getting more Immaculate rather than
more messy so you're right that the data
came in I would say
consistent with but on the high side of
expectations so and if you go back to
the old the former SCP the last SCP in
March you will see that growth moved up
these are not huge moves but growth
estimates moved up a bit unemployment
estimates moved down a bit inflation has
it's moved up a bit and you know the all
three of those kind of point in the same
direction which is you know that perhaps
more restraint will be necessary than we
had thought at the last meeting so
although the level frankly is is pretty
the level of 5.6 is pretty consistent if
you think about it where the federal
funds rate was trading before the bank
incidents of early March so but so we've
kind of gone back to that so your
question is where is it where's the
disinflation going to come from and you
know I don't think the story has really
changed we the committee has
consistently said and believed that the
process of getting inflation down is
going to be a gradual one it's going to
take some time and uh I think you go
back to the to the three-part framework
for core pce inflation which is we think
of as good an indicators you can have
for where inflation is going forward you
start with Goods with Goods we need to
see continued healing and Supply
conditions supply side conditions
they've definitely improved a
substantial amount but if you talk to
people in business they will say it's
not back to where it was so that's
that's one thing and that should enable
Goods prices to continue because because
inflation to continue to come down over
time in terms of Housing Services
inflation that's another big piece and
and you are seeing there that new rents
new new leases are are coming in at low
levels and it's really a matter of time
as that goes through the pipeline in
fact I think any forecasts that people
are making right now about inflation
coming down this year will will contain
a big dose of this year and next year
we'll contain a a good amount of of uh
disinflation from that source and and
that's again probably going to come
slower than we would affect that leaves
you know the big sector which is a
little more than half pardon me of the
uh of core PC inflation that's
non-housing services and you know we see
only the earliest signs of disinflation
there it's a sector it's a very Broad
and diverse sector I would say in a
number of the parts of that sector the
largest cost would be wage costs it's a
service center or so it's it's heavily
labor intensive and I think many
analysts would say that the key to
getting inflation down there is to have
a continuing loosening in labor market
conditions which we have seen we have
actually seen you know go through a
number of indicators suggesting there's
been some losing in labor market
conditions we need to see that continue
I would almost say that the the
conditions that we need to see in place
to get inflation down
are coming into place and that would be
growing growth meaningfully below Trend
it would be a labor market that's
loosening it would be good pipelines
getting healthier and healthier and that
kind of thing but there there the things
are in place that we need to see but the
process of that actually working on
inflation is going to take some time
Nick tamrose of the Wall Street Journal
uh chair pal what's the value in pausing
and signaling future hikes versus uh
just hiking now I mean not to be
flippant but I don't lose weight just by
buying a gym membership I have to
actually go to the gym 16 of your
colleagues put down a higher year-end 23
rate today a majority of you think
you're going to have to go up by 50
basis points this year so why not just
rip off the Band-Aid and raise rates
today
so that at first I would say that the
the question of speed is a separate
question from the question from the from
from that of level okay so
um and I think if you look at the SCP
that is our estimate our individual is
it's really accumulation of our
individual estimates of how far to go I
I mentioned how how we got to those
numbers in terms of speed it's it's what
I said at the beginning which is speed
was very important last year as we get
closer and closer to the destination and
according to the SCP we're not so far
away from the destination in most
people's accounting uh it's it's
reasonable it's common sense to go a
little slower just as it was reasonable
to go from 75 basis points to 50 to 25
at every meeting and so uh the committee
thought overall that it was appropriate
to moderate the pace if only slightly
and their benefits to that so that gives
us more information to make decisions we
may try to make better decisions I think
it allows the economy a little more time
to adapt as we as we may make our
decisions going forward and we'll get to
see you know we haven't really we don't
know the full extent of of the
consequences of the banking turmoil that
we've seen we it would be early to see
those but we don't know what the extent
is we'll have some more time to see that
unfolding it's just the idea that we're
trying to get this right and uh this is
if you think of the two things as
separate variables then I think I think
that the the skip I shouldn't call to
skip the the decision
um uh makes sense I know you said July
is live with only one June employment uh
with only the June employment and the
CPI report for June uh due to be
released before the July meeting you get
the ECI after you get the senior loan
officer survey after you get some Bank
earnings at the end of next month what
incremental information will the
committee be using to inform their
judgment on whether this is in fact a
skip or a longer pause well I think
you're adding that to the the data that
we've seen since the last meeting too
you know we since we chose to maintain
rates at this meeting is it'll really be
a three-month period of data that we can
look at I think that's a full quarter
and I think you can you can draw more
conclusions from that than you come from
any six any six week period we'll look
at those things we'll also look at the
evolving risk picture we'll look at
what's happening in the financial sector
we'll look at all the data the evolving
Outlook and we'll make a decision
Gina
thanks for taking our questions Gina
smile like New York Times you obviously
in your forecast marked up the sort of
path for growth marked down the path for
unemployment marked up the path for
inflation pretty notably I wonder you
know since March what has changed to
make you think that the economy is a lot
more resilient and inflation is going to
be a lot more stubborn and given that
you know why do you feel confident that
this is as high as you're going to have
to revise the federal funds rate or do
you think it's possible we could have
even a higher than 5.6 terminal by the
end of this this cycle
you know I I mean on the first part I
just think we're following the data and
also the Outlook the economy is the
labor market I think has surprised many
if not all analysts over the last couple
of years with its
extraordinary resilience really and
um it's it's just remarkable and that's
really if you think about it that's
what's driving it's it's job creation
it's it's uh wages moving up it's it's
supporting spending which in turn is
supporting hiring and it's it's really
the engine it seems that is that is
driving the economy
so it's it's really the data in terms of
you know we we always write down at
these meetings what we think the
appropriate terminal rate will be at the
end of this year that's that's how we do
it
um it's based on uh our our own
individual assessments of what the most
likely
path of the economy is
it can be it can actually in reality
wind up being lower or higher and you
know there's really no way to know but
it's it's it is it's it's what people
think as of today and as the as the data
come in it it can move around during the
intermediate period It could wind up
back in the same place but it really
will be data driven I can't I can't tell
you that that I ever have a lot of
confidence that we can see where the
where the federal funds rate will be
that far in advance
Mr chairman thanks for my question um
you had said back at the end of May that
you thought risks were getting closer to
being into balance is that still the
case or has your mind changed about the
balance of risks out there and also
could you give us an idea of what would
be a sufficiently restrictive funds rate
is the obviously the current rate
according to the committee is not
sufficiently restrictive is it five six
is it six words for sufficiently
restrictive thank you
um you know I I would say again that I
think that over time the balance of
risks as we've moved from very you know
from interest rates at effectively zero
now to five percentage points with with
an SCP calling for additional hikes I
think we've moved much closer to our
destination which is that sufficiently
restrictive rate and I think that means
by almost by definition that the the
risks of of sort of overdoing it and
under underdoing it are are getting
closer to being in Balance I still think
and my my colleagues agree that that the
risks to inflation are to the upside
still so we don't we don't think we're
there with inflation yet because we're
just looking at the data if you look at
the uh
um at the full range of of inflation
data particularly the core data you just
you just aren't seeing a lot of progress
over the last year headline of course
inflation has come down materially but
as you know we look at core as a better
indicator of where inflation overall is
going
was officially so I think you know what
what we'd like to see is credible
evidence that inflation is topping out
and then beginning to come down that's
that's what we want to see of course
that's what we want to see and
um
I I think
it's also we understand that there are
lags but remember that it's it's more
than a year since Financial conditions
began tightening I think it's I think
the reason we're we're comfortable
pausing is that we are still much of the
tightening took place over last summer
and later into the year and I think it's
it's reasonable to think that some of
that may come into effect so we're you
know I think stretching out the into a
more moderate pace is appropriate to to
allow you to make that Judgment of
sufficiency you know more with more data
over time
thanks for taking your questions I
wanted to ask further on the lag effects
when you're considering when you would
hike again throughout the course of the
year are there things that you would
expect to kick in as those lag effects
come come into effect that would inform
your decisions have you learned things
over the past year that give you some
sense of timeline for when to expect
those lags to come into effect
so
it it's a it's a challenging
thing in economics it's it's sort of
standard thinking that monetary policy
affects economic activity with long and
variable legs
of course these days Financial
conditions begin to tighten well in
advance of actual rate hikes so if you
if you look back when we were lifting
off we started talking about lifting off
by the time we had lifted off the
two-year which is a pretty good estimate
of where policy is going had gone from
20 basis points to 200 basis points so
in that sense
tightening happens much sooner than it
used to in a world where where news was
in newspapers and not you know not on on
The Wire
so that's that's different but it's
still the case that what you see is
intra-sensitive spending is affected
very very quickly so housing and durable
goods and things like that but broader
demand and spending and and asset values
and things like that they just take
longer and you can pretty much find
research to support whatever answer you
would like on that so there's not any
certainty or agreement in the profession
on how long it takes so you know then
that makes it challenging of course so
we're we're looking at the calendar
we're looking at what's happening in the
economy we're having to make these
judgments and again it's one of the main
reasons why it makes sense to go at a
slightly more moderate Pace now as we
seek that that uh ultimate yeah I can't
point to um that ultimate endpoint I
can't point to a specific data point I
think we'll see it when we see inflation
you know really really flattening out
reliably and then starting to soften I
think we'll know that we're that it's
working and ideally by by taking a
little more time we won't go well past
the air the level where we need to go
I was curious if you could
tightening since the
spring March and how you're teasing that
out apart from these lag effects so it's
it's too early still to to try to assess
the full extent of what that might mean
and you know that's something we're
going to be watching of course and you
know if we were to see what we would
view as significant tightening beyond
what would normally be expected because
of this channel then you know we would
factor that into account on on uh in
making rate decisions so that's um
that's how we think about it
Chris
uh thanks Chris reuber and Associated
Press you mentioned that many of the
trends are in place that you want to see
uh core Services X housing has come in
pretty low in the past couple of months
and as you noted a significant portion
of core inflation is now housing prices
and then we've had some quirks in used
car prices so given that these Trends
are in place I guess I'm sort of asking
the flip side of Nick's question why uh
signal additional rate hikes aren't
things headed in the direction you need
why not simply give it even more time or
uh I mean it's surprising to see so much
hawkishness in the dots given what we're
seeing recently yeah so you know we've
remember we've um
were
two and a half years into this or two
and a quarter years into this and
forecasters including
fed forecasters have consistently
thought that inflation was about to turn
down and uh you know traditional and not
you know typically forecasted that it
would and been wrong so I think if you I
think if you look at the at core pce
inflation overall
look at it over the last six months
you're just not seeing a lot of progress
It's running and it's running at a level
you know over four and a half percent
far above our
our Target and not really you know
moving down we want to see it moving
down decisively that's all we're you
know of course we are going to get
inflation down to two percent over time
we don't want to do we want to do that
with the minimum damage we can to the
economy of course but we have to get
inflation out of two percent and we will
and we just don't see that yet so
hints you see today's policy decision
both to write down for the rate hikes by
the end of this year but also to you
know to take uh to moderate somewhat the
pace with which we're moving
a quick follow-up I mean the last press
conference you mentioned you didn't see
wages driving inflation and you know
there was some research from the San
Francisco feds suggesting wages aren't
necessarily a key driver but you've
talked about the labor market today and
the need for softening can you give us a
little more specifically of how you see
the tight labor market driving inflation
at this point thank you right so um
I'm not going to comment on on any
particular paper but I would say that
the I think the overall picture is that
at the beginning in you know early 2021
inflation was really becoming from very
strong demand for largely for goods
people were still at home they had money
in the bank and they wanted to spend
they spent a lot on goods and of course
at the same time and because of that
high demand to some extent Supply chains
got all snarled up so prices went way up
inflation went way up that was the the
origin it wasn't really particularly
about the labor market or wages but as
you as you move into through 21 into 22
and now in 23 I think many many analysts
believe that it will be important an
important part of getting inflation down
especially in the non-housing services
sector
uh getting wage inflation back to a
level that is sustainable that is
consistent with two percent inflation we
actually have seen wages broadly moved
down but just at a quite gradual pace so
and that's you know that's a little bit
of the uh the finding of the Bernanke
paper
with uh Blanchard of a few weeks ago
which is very consistent with um with
what I I would think
Michael McKee from Bloomberg Radio and
uh television you said in the past that
you don't like to surprise markets it's
kind of been The fed's View Market
should have an idea of what you're going
to do before you go in you also said a
number of times that it would take a
while to bring inflation down you
reiterated that again today and that we
would get to a point where inflation
could be sticky so I'm wondering as we
go into the next meetings how Wall
Street or others should look at your
reaction function what will you be
reacting to time or data in other words
if nothing much changes if we're looking
at the same sort of Labor Market the
same sort of inflation levels in July or
in September uh or November will you
move because you've said you feel you
need to is it time that's going to
require additional movement or would it
be reversal in inflation
so I I don't want to deal with with
hypotheticals about different ways data
might move out so we you know we of
course we're not we don't go out of our
way to surprise markets or the public at
the same time our main focus has to be
on getting the policy right and that's
that's what we're doing here and that's
what we'll do for the upcoming meetings
I will say the July meeting will be live
and uh we'll just have to see I think
you'll you'll see the data you'll hear
fed people talking about it and and
markets will have to make a make a
judgment well do you think inflation is
likely to continue coming down based on
the lags and based on your threat of
additional movement or are we going to
be in a period where we're not going to
know what's happening
you know I think if you look at uh
if you just look at I'll just point you
to the forecast so inflation is running
core PCS inflation is running in about
four and a half a little higher than
four and a half percent and the the
median fomc participant thinks it'll go
down to 3.9 on a 12 month basis this is
by the end of this year so that's
expecting pretty substantial progress
that's that's that's a pretty
significant decline for half a year so
that that's that that's the forecast
um you know we'll we do try to be
transparent in our reaction function
we're we're committed to getting
inflation down and uh that's the number
one thing so that's how I think about it
let's go to Victoria
um Victoria Guido with Politico could
you talk about the balance sheet and how
you're thinking about it what would what
are you looking for to judge whether
we're approaching Reserve scarcity and
his treasury issues going to affect that
also are you considering lowering the
RRP rate in order to take some pressure
off Banks
so let me say first of all on the
treasury part of it if I can talk about
that and then go back to the balance
sheet so on that of course we've been
very focused on that for a couple of
months as everyone has treasury has laid
out its boring borrowing plans publicly
I think we all saw I saw the secretary's
comments yesterday to the effect that
treasury has consulted widely with
Market participants about how to avoid
Market disruption and that they're going
to watch carefully for that so that's
that's from The Drew which actually sets
the you know the the borrowings at the
FED we'll be monitoring market
conditions carefully as the treasury
refills the the TGA the adjustment
process is very likely to involve both
the reduction in the RRP facility and
also in reserves
it's really hard to say at the at the
beginning of this which will be which
will be greater
we are starting at a very high level of
reserves and still elevated RRP to take
up for that matter so we don't think
reserves are likely to become scarce in
the near term or even over the course of
the year
um so that's that's that's the that's
the the treasury part of the answer
um we will of course continue to monitor
um conditions in money markets and we're
prepared to make adjustments to make
sure that that uh monetary policy
transmission works
was there another part of your question
during lowering the RRP rate to help
take some pressure off Banks so we have
a number of I would say the RRP doesn't
look like it's it's pulling money out of
out of the banking system it's actually
been shrinking here lately uh so I don't
think uh that's not something something
we've we've thought about a lot over
time it doesn't really look like that's
that's something we would do I think
it's I think it's a tool that we have if
we want to use it we can there are other
tools we can we can use to address money
market issues but I wouldn't say that
that's something that's likely that we
would do in the near term
I don't know
Janelle Marte with Bloomberg
um have you seen sufficient Cooling in
the housing market to bring inflation
down for example how does the recent
rebound affect your forecast and how
does it factor into monetary policy
so certainly housing very interest
sensitive and it's the first place
really one of the first places that's
either helped by low rates or or that is
held backed by by higher rates and we
certainly saw that over the course of
the last year we now see housing putting
in a bottom and maybe even moving up a
little bit
um you know we're watching that
situation carefully I do think uh we we
will see rents rents and and house
prices filtering into
into Housing Services inflation and I
don't see them coming up quickly I do
see them coming kind of wandering around
at a relatively low level now and uh
that's appropriate
do you think you'll have to Target uh
with further rate increases well I think
we look at everything we don't just look
at housing so I think you know the way
it works is individual participants sit
in their offices all over the country
and they write down their their forecast
and including their most likely forecast
including their rate forecast and then
they send it in on Friday afternoon and
we accumulate it and then we publish it
for you
so that's how that's how they do that
well I don't know that housing is is is
itself going to be driving the rates
picture but it's part of it
if you're taking the question Mr
chairman Edward Lawrence with Fox
Business so I want to go back to
comments you made about um in the past
about unsustainable fiscal path the CBO
projects the federal deficit to be 2.8
trillion uh in 10 years the CBO also
says that federal debt would be 52
trillion by 2033 at what point do you
talk more firmly with lawmakers about
fiscal responsibility because I'm
assuming monetary policy cannot handle
alone the inflation or keep that
inflation in check with the higher level
spending
I don't do that that's really not my job
we we we hope and expect that other
policy makers will respect our
independence on on monetary policy
and we don't see ourselves as uh as you
know the judges of appropriate fiscal
policy I will say and many of my
predecessors have said that we are on an
unsustainable fiscal path and that needs
to be addressed over time but I think
trying to get into uh
into that with with lawmakers would be
would be kind of
inappropriate given our independence and
our need to stick to our knitting is
there any conversation then about the
Federal Reserve financing some of that
debt that we're seeing coming down the
pike no under no circumstances
Courtney
uh thanks for taking our questions uh
chair Powell
um so looking at the SCP it looks like a
GDP for this year was raised
significantly your forecast for GDP this
year uh the unemployment rate meanwhile
was pulled downward and so should we
take that as a sign that the committee
is more confident about the prospects of
a soft landing at least more uh at least
as it relates to what you're expecting
in in March
you know I
I would just say it this way I continue
to think and this really hasn't changed
that there is a path to uh
getting inflation back down to two
percent
without having to see the kind of sharp
downturn and and large losses of
employment that we've seen in so many
past and since it's it's possible a in a
way a strong labor market uh is uh that
gradually cools could it could Aid that
along it could Aid that along but I
guess I want to come back to the the
main thing which is though simply this
we we see the committee as you can see
from the SCP the committee is completely
unified in the need to get inflation
down to two percent and we'll do
whatever it takes to get it down to two
percent over time that is our plan
and uh you know we we understand that
allowing inflation to get entrenched
into the in the U.S economy is the thing
that we cannot cannot allow to happen
for the benefit of today's workers and
families and businesses but also for the
future
getting price stability back and and
restored will benefit generations of
people as long as it's sustained and it
really is the Bedrock of the economy and
you should understand that that is our
top priority
just a quick follow-up on that I'm just
a little confused because you said the
committee will do whatever it takes to
get inflation down over time but when I
look at the SCP inflation is still
projected to be elevated next year but
the FED funds rate is lower than where
it is now can you help me understand
that sure so um you know if you look two
and three years out with the forecast
first of all I wouldn't I wouldn't put
too much weight on forecasts even one
year out because they're so highly
uncertain but what they're showing is
that as inflation comes down in the in
the forecast if you don't lower interest
rates then real rates are actually going
up right so it just to maintain a real
rate the nominal rate at that point two
years out let's say should come down
just to maintain real rates and if and
actually you know since we we're we're
probably gonna we're we're having real
rates that are going to have to be
meaningfully positive
uh and significantly so for us to get
inflation down that probably means that
that certainly means that that it will
be appropriate to cut rates at such time
as inflation is coming down
really significantly and again we're
talking about a couple years out I think
as anyone can see not a single person on
the committee wrote down a rate cut this
year nor do I think it is uh at all
likely to be appropriate if you think
about it inflation has not really moved
down it is it is not uh so far reacted
much to our to our existing rate hikes
and so we're gonna have to keep at it
I'm sorry thank you
AFP news agency the major reports showed
a rebound in May in a black rockers and
unemployment
um is it consistent with the fed's
maximum employment mandate are you
worried about that about this rebound
we are of course worried about uh there
are long-standing difference differences
in racial and ethnic groups across
across our labor market that's a factor
that we don't we can't really address
with our tools but we do consider that
when we're thinking about what
constitutes maximum employment it is for
us a broad and inclusive goal
um and so we do watch that but remember
uh
all unemployment including black
unemployment has been bouncing around
right near historic lows historic modern
lows here so we're still talking about I
mean what is as strong a labor market as
we've seen in you know a half century
here in the United States so overall
unemployment of 3.7 percent is is is
three tenths higher than it was a
measured to be at the last uh
a month ago but still it's
extraordinarily low and so it's a very
very tight labor market
Megan
thank you I want to follow up uh first a
little bit just on the rent question on
housing we heard Governor Waller talk
about how we I'll back up we haven't
quite seen the slowdown in rent show up
in CPI yet and we did hear Governor
Waller talk about how an uptick in
housing might mean that there's not
going to be as much relief coming or a
shorter bit of relief than we thought
can you talk about how you're thinking
about that and how that played into
today's outcome I wouldn't say so that's
you know as a factual matter that's
correct we do need to see you know rents
bottom out here or at least stay quite
low
in terms of their increases because we
want we want the um you know we want
inflation to come down and Rental uh is
is a very large part of the CPI about a
third and it's about half of that for
the pce so it's important and so we're
something that we're watching very
carefully it's part of the overall
picture I wouldn't say it's the decisive
part but take a step back what you see
is look at look at core inflation over
the past six months a year you're just
not seeing a lot of progress not the
kind of progress we want to see and uh
that that's it's hard to avoid that and
you know the committee
people in the committee the median went
up significantly so that the median
participant now thinks that core pce
inflation on a 12-month basis will be
3.9 percent this year so once again
every year for the past three years it's
gone up over the course of the year and
that's doing that again so we see that
and we see that inflation forecasts are
coming in low again and we see that that
that tells us that we need to do more
and so we're that's why you see the SCP
with where it is could you also talk
briefly about your outlook for wages and
given the recent slowdown in core
Services excluding housing how far you
think we just might need to fall in
order to to get inflation back in line
so wages will continue to increase so we
you know what we're talking about is
having wage increases still at a very
strong level but at a level that's
consistent with two percent inflation
over time and so I think we've seen some
progress all of the major measures of
wages have have moved down from extreme
highly elevated levels a year or so ago
and they're they're moving back down but
but quite gradually and and you know we
want to see that that process continue
gradually of course
it's great to see wage increases
particularly for people at the lower end
of the income Spectrum but we want that
as part of the process of getting
inflation back down to two percent which
benefits everyone I mean inflation hurts
those same people more than anyone else
people on a fixed income or hurt the
worst and the fastest by high inflation
thank you so much chairpower Greg Robb
from MarketWatch
I just wondered if the committee has
talked at all about the labor market and
and there's strikes now in Hollywood and
now the United Auto Workers are talking
about a possible strike I mean aren't
workers they we have some workers have
power now and are going to be seeking
higher wages does that come up in your
discussions thanks
so the topic of wages in the labor
market and Dynamics in the labor market
could is about as Central a topic to our
discussions as as anything I mean it's
it's very labor economics you know and
the labor market are utterly Central you
know it's half of our mandate so we
spend a lot of time talking about that I
think um you know we
there are structural issues that are
really not for the fed and so we don't
spend a lot of time although we take
notice of of what's going on but we're
not you know we're not involved in
discussions or debates over over strikes
and things like that but we you know we
we look and we see what's going on and
you know we're making judgments about
what it will take to get inflation down
to two percent in the Aggregate and as I
said don't think that was about I didn't
think most folks would say now it wasn't
really about that about wages at the
beginning and it's becoming more about
that as we as we get into uh really
service sector inflation which is the
part of the economy where we have seen
the least progress
let's go to mark for the last question
thank you Mr chairman Mark Hamrick with
Bankrate wondering what your thoughts
are now about systemic risk now that
we're about three months past the
failure of Silicon Valley Bank and also
specifically what are the risks
associated with commercial real estate
as well as non-bank financials and could
you further Elevate those risks with
higher still rates possibly for longer
so um
foreign
with commercial real estate we of course
were watching that situation very
carefully uh there's a substantial
amount of commercial real estate in the
banking system a large part of it is in
smaller Banks it's well distributed to
the extent it's well distributed then
then the system could could take losses
we do expect that there will be losses
but there'll be there'll be banks that
have concentrations and those banks will
experience larger losses so we're well
aware of that we're monitoring it
carefully
um you know it feels like it feels like
something that will be around for some
time
as opposed to uh
you know something that will suddenly
hit and and you know work its way into
systemic risk in terms of non-bank
financials
financial sector
um
there's been a ton of work and you know
clearly in the um in the pandemic it
really was uh it was the non-bank
financial sector where where issues
really arose and you know there's a lot
of work going on in with the
administration uh in particular leading
that to try to address issues in the
treasury market and and uh in all kinds
of areas in non-bank financial market
and but you know our jurisdiction at the
FED is over Banks actually Bank holding
companies and some banks so that's
that's really our main focus
um you know in terms of
um the events of March as I mentioned
earlier we will be carefully monitoring
that situation you know our our job
generally involves worrying about a lot
of things uh that may go wrong that
would include the banks it might be hard
for me to identify something and that we
don't worry about rather than that we do
worry about so we're watching those
things very carefully and as we see
things unfold as we see what's happening
with credit conditions and and also all
the individual banks that are out there
you know will be able to take to the
extent it's appropriate we can take if
they're macroeconomic implications we
can take that into account in our rate
setting and uh so I guess that's what I
would say
do you do you risk further exacerbating
those issues if you get up to another 50
basis points so that's and I was I guess
I meant to address that by saying as we
as we watch we'll see what's happening
and if we if we're seeing the kind of um
tightening of conditions that you could
be referring to then we can factor that
because really we use our our rate tool
is is you know is it really has
macroeconomic purposes so we'll take
that into account of course we have
responsibility for financial stability
as well and that also is a factor that
we're always going to be considering
thank you very much
[Music]